[MUSIC PLAYING]
LASSE: Hi, I'm Lasse.
ANDREAS: Hi, I'm Andreas.
LASSE: This is an experiment
called Teachable Machine.
It makes it easier
for anyone to start
exploring how machine learning
works, live in the browser,
no coding required.
ANDREAS: Over here is
the input, my camera.
And here are the three classes;
green, purple, and orange.
And over here is the output.
This is where the
machine responds to you.
Right now, it's set to respond
with one of these three gifs.
You can change these gifs
to any gifs you want.
First, I'm going to
teach the green class
to recognize when I put
my hand up, like this,
and show a cat gif.
I just hold down the green
button for a couple of seconds.
So now it's training
the green class.
And there.
Now you see that the green bar
is up with high confidence,
and it's showing the cat gif.
But you'll notice that green
is up no matter what I do.
If the hand's up or down.
That's because the machine
is looking at my input
and deciding which class
it's most similar to.
But since I've only
trained one class,
everything looks most
similar to that one.
That's why I need to
teach it a second class.
So now, with my hand down,
I'll hold this purple button
for a couple of seconds.
And it's training
the purple class.
And there.
Now it's working.
When I put my hand
up, the green class
triggers with the cat gif.
And when I put my hand
down, the purple class
triggers with the dog gif.
Up, down, up, and down.
What if I raised my
hand just a little bit?
It's kind of confused.
The bars are wriggling
around because it's not sure.
Is it the green class
or the purple class?
If I raise my
right hand instead,
you'll see that
the machine still
recognizes that this is more
similar to the green class,
which is kind of interesting.
Let me try to train this
orange class with a crazy face,
like this.
So now when I make that face,
it should trigger the last bunny
gif.
It works.
And I can also switch to speech.
Now when my hand is
up, it says hello.
COMPUTER: Hello.
ANDREAS: And when my hand
is down, it says awesome.
COMPUTER: Awesome.
ANDREAS: And I can
change these to anything.
Like, oh, cool.
COMPUTER: Hello.
Oh, cool.
LASSE: The point of all this
is to let you start digging
into machine learning
in a hands-on way.
Like sometimes, your
machine might not work.
You can learn a lot by
thinking about your examples
and trying different approaches.
You can even try to confuse
it on purpose, which can
be a really fun way to learn.
It's built with a library
code, deeplearn.js.
This let you train and run
machine learning models locally
in the browser, which is what
makes it respond so fast.
And deeplearn.js works
on mobile devices too,
so you can try this experiment
with the camera on your phone.
You can get the code and
start teaching your machine
at g.co/teachablemachine.